let's dive into this so we got number
one
uh every woman has a price whether it be
physical emotional
social status impressing her peers
competing with her peers or financial
games
explain what you mean by that so
everyone's got a price right everyone
some people at the really cheap price
sometimes it takes a perfect storm and
every possible condition to make it
happen but like anytime you get a
government job or anything with high
security they check if you have that if
you have any way that you can easily
persuade the
give up sensitive information so when it
comes to women there's
always going to be a price sometimes
it's just attention hey they're not
getting it at home
and that's what like you know as dancers
we're selling that fantasies
and they don't get physical hey they got
a guy who hasn't worked out since you
know
grade 12 gym class they got a guy six
who you know abs big arms you know
everything she reads in a romance novel
you got other people who
lost a guy maybe he's a hockey player
maybe this guy's a lawyer a doctor
whatever the social status is versus the
guy who's making a buck over minimum
wage right
so she sees that and back to that guy
too he's making
a um income versus
you know barely paying the bills so that
that's appealing whatever it is there's
always gonna be something
that's gonna sell her to step out out of
her normal realm
of what her morals are and do something
that you normally wouldn't do
because this other guy's got something
that's just appealing like you're
hypergamy you're always talking about
that with this woman it's just
a perfect example of it you know they
come in these shows
you guys pretending to be real heroes
maybe firefighters pretend to be cops
get more gratification recognition than
the real heroes get
and guys you're probably making not that
much
and they're willing to throw away
everything just don't have a round or
two with this guy
that could be less about them the next
day and
and really what it is is just finding
the deal and as we know
uh social media a half decent woman with
edited filtered pictures
holds a picture you know hey i i got no
sleep tonight but i still look beautiful
or you know and then you got all these
losers
hitting them up yeah you got the same
thing with the women too right you just
give them a little bit of that
gratification and uh
you just find out what they want and it
can be outside the trip and you can sell
any girl anything you want and then
that's how easy it is it's not just that
description
this this is just a prime breeding
ground to see how dirty people are when
you're not looking
for this it's the lawyer she's falling
for next week
so um when it comes to these type of
type of um gatherings like
you said earlier on that you know
compared to
um strip joints or bachelor parties that
you've been to
like men are tame compared to women
right absolutely
the things that men do are
very mild in comparison and i'm talking
just just the way they act
encouraging others women will encourage
their best friend that steps
outside the relationship just because it
seems like a good time tonight
and do they all figure that you know
because we're all together and
you know it's a bachelorette's party or
what happens in vegas or what happens in
new york just stays there
you know stays there for the weekend
like do they feel like there's that
level of blanket security
and that and that's what is you know
what a girl will never
rat out another girl you know if a girl
sees a guy she wants and she knows he's
in a relationship and he says hey i'm in
a relationship
if she wants it she's gonna go for it if
she knows he's in a relationship
and he denies it she'll just tell
everyone oh my god i didn't know
so they always look out for them they
don't want to look sleazy they're not
going to wrap their friends out and
they're not going to wrap their friends
up because they encouraged it they told
them to do it
i'd say about 80 of the time girls go
home with from the guys because they're
pushed
into it by their girlfriends i mean
they're doing it by their own free will
but
that's the deciding factor right that's
where i talk about this whole
the social image right like you know
impressing her peers
and that's why they'll do it um if i
would go to a group of girls
they're five girls or really attractive
and there's always that one girl who
just doesn't fit in
that's gonna be the motherhood and
that's gonna be the boss there's a
reason with those four
attractive girls if she's getting laid
everyone's getting laid shane getting
laid no one's getting late so if you
if you suck up to her and you make her
night and encourage everyone else to do
whatever you want
do women behave differently at private
bachelorette parties versus like a strip
joint like
if a few women get together at a male
strip joint for the night
is is it different behavior from a
bachelorette party where they
reserve like a hall and a couple of guys
show up and jump out of a cake and all
that
yeah it's it's uh comparable but it's
pretty different
you know when you go to the trip show
most of the time when it's over like i
said the majority of the crowd's like oh
oh you know i stepped out of my
relationship a little bit got a lap
dance slap some ass whatever
i'm going home i'm good right but when
you're at the bachelorette party
you kind of get like that mob mentality
one person does it and they all start
doing there's no time limit there's no
leaving there's no show you're already
you know you already run from the bar to
the home you're already at the place
where it's going to happen
every single time i've done one of those
parties other than a handful there's
always been an opportunity there's
always been a girl slipping me a number
there's always been a girl asking for a
private dance wants more than the dance
there's always something going on
and uh you know as i progressed to my
career i stayed further and further away
from that because nothing good can
happen
because my boyfriends they got husbands
more than likely that boyfriend or
husband owns that house that you're in
and it's going to be bad news for you
even though she's the one who
suggested it and consented to that right
you gotta blame the guy
every time
you